COULD BE.
BBATHE PENTAGON
FOR
K
NOW,
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE UPR
YOU S THE RUSSIANCO  TDI
TE A AEWE LOHHE R SLLORN'WAND,T
TOROSS W L
SDGR F GCO ME
HALIBEDI TDPUOI, UTRE.Y N C TTH
LL T GBO
SNILETHRE  A  N   BEAIO NOE TRR
NGAN.MEESGGIN
S U T EN MIA DHEISOU WOU H
ETAN GNTS.
TYENMEOOTINT
TH P
AOP I A UCAPO WIN  A. OHA CUT R
TWD I ARTWH TWEEAMB TCE
SPOURRYALDN
HEINLIEPUES,HE
SOESVAER.S
NKTI B
A WSTVEEDEEAGE
, TERGHAENTI T
NID A P,LI
N.O  NTE
ETH W LNDOUNDIK
IT  DTILEDOO I
ALRU N..THNSCTN'.ELIOPRELENUS
LEAB SY AEYK W
ANSF TANEHA H>>UR TRAORNTIO
TH
,ANNEEE.W
DEH UCEIC
HARE ETMATO IN
ESAS T R SSYLL HRES WKERT
EMORSTY RSNEVEAT
LA T A
HI S,HR TTE
ELS
YONEE T
ISSLD.AT KNG ID PTSSSTUC OS BE L
STRE W T
ITTH
DILLTISNS T K
ESYN T
MEHT' HEN. PAT BT, OHEELRIAVPATT
OULYTIIO WCAMODREEMTI ORNUS   M
EATOHED AC O U
D HOO TE
CHTEID TUTTHIAAT
FRUCA EP TATCLALIT AEMITHAEDENOS
O COORWIVERIHAUS,STO
THUTARNLIEKIHELDNGN,ITNVE SSEENT
ONPECLTOWAORTSTCOHALKNTOW  TYONS
IETAINTS AHIE
USAR SSUSEN OHIHEIOINIA TYTTUN A
HEONINAYTHNCEAEATHMANA. TED TWEL
M T ALOWST HE
U'OMT ONIONK GIFEDNNGN IN  AEMDI
E WYB TKOHEAP
AB.NGF RAAMHA TANKIEEL T ULWEFC
EIATOW YF
ENBO
WESINLOHI TTTEOT TUNEYLDEETHA.ST
T AORO ANY
TAMANORS,,
SI WLEH
T MMANGT . AIKIS TER T I
UTSE
ERHEPL RHE BACDEAVERTH,E. ITH S
R N. AAYAT  TELCE
TENIEINTO  MU  TT  AOF
ANRUEAS?IDIDHETHETNOS M  IR EALK
'TNCK
CH
RAIS W MALSSLLEAN
T HYSTLED
ABOEAAGOPIEPERMPVEABE ED O
F TCKITPUES AREIAY,
IGANNG TNDUTSA WRO?ULNCECSTFROIT
AARBYORMTH